je viens vous parler de réchauffement
climatique et de l'effondrement du
vivant
on va parler de biodiversité
de gaz à effet de serre
on va parler des mécanismes
de l'acidification des océans
et de l'augmentation en fréquence et en
intensité des événements extrêmes
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là
qu'est ce que vous ressentez
regardez bien ce que vous ressentez
vous venez de mettre le doigt sur la
principale cause de l'inaction
climatique
on veut pas regarder
parce que c'est désagréable
c'est technique c'est compliquer
scientifique
et regarder les émotions que ça vous
ramène
la colère
la tristesse
toutes les formes de peur
et vous la voyez là là bien caché là
cette petite dose de culpabilité
ce qu'on sait tous qu'on pourrait faire
un peu plus
alors on va tout faire pour détourner le
regard à chaque fois que le sujet se
présente devant nous
et moi ce soir je vais vous aider
je viens vous aider et vous présenter
trois techniques
pour détourner le regard à chaque fois
que le sujet va se présenter devant vous
alors technique numéro un ça n'existe
pas il n'y a pas de changement
climatique
oui c'est des cycles naturels évidemment
ou en tout cas s'il y en a un c'est
sûrement pas la faute de l'homme
alors pour vous en convaincre c'est très
simple vous prenez votre moteur de
recherche préféré
et vous tapez
canular changement climatique en anglais
ça marche mieux cry macho hawks
pour garder une ou deux vidéos
vous verrez c'est très très bien fait au
bout d'un moment le système va vous
ramener plein d'autres vidéos en deux
jours vous sentirez au mieux
je vous donne un petit truc
supplémentaires
vous trouvez un phénomène mal connu
un peu déroutant
et vous n'hésitez pas à le glisser à
chaque fois que le sujet devient
devant vous
par exemple savez vous quel est le gaz à
effet de serre qu'on trouve en plus
forte concentration dans l'atmosphère
non
non c'est pas le co2 non
non c'est la vapeur d'eau
d'ici je vous laisse vérifier
avec ça vous êtes tranquille pour un
moment
alors je vous cache pas que c'est une
technique qui a ses limites
pourquoi parce que à un moment ou un
autre vous aurez un premier de la classe
qui va venir vous parler des vestaires
naturel effet de serre additionnel
cycle de l'eau
technique numéro 2
la technique numéro 2
la technologie va nous sauver
évidemment
l'homme s'est toujours sortie de
l'adversité et c'est même au pied du mur
qui lie 9 le mieux n'est ce pas
tenus il ya quelques semaines ça fait la
une c'est en islande ils ont fait une
usine de direct car
elles capturent le co2 directement dans
l'atmosphère et val l'enfouir dans les
sous-sols
et elle promet d'enfouir jusqu'à 4000
tonnes de co2 tous les ans
alors le truc avec cette technique s'il
faut être agile il faut savoir rebondir
à l'aide d'une technique à une autre
pourquoi pas parce que les chiffres sont
têtus et que le premier de la classe
toujours le même reviendra avec des
ordres de grandeurs 4000 tonnes de co2
par an c'est pas mal mais tu sais qu'on
en est mais 100 millions de tonnes
par jour
d'où la technique numéro 3 est la
technique la plus robuste celle qui vous
tiendra le plus longtemps sur la durée
technique est très simple vous trouver
un coupable
alors c'est qui le coupable dans cette
affaire eh ben c'est celui que vous
voulez
si possible le plus éloigné de vous
la faute des chinois premier émetteur de
gaz à effet serre
ta faute des américains vous avez vu
leur mode de vie
la faute des riches évidemment
sa faute des fautes des pauvres non
après tout là c'est pas un problème de
démographie cette affaire
sapho des lieux de vote des jeunes ça
fait des politiques c'est la faute des
entreprises leur direction de leurs
actionnaires
sapho du capitalisme
la faute du système quoi
c'est une très bonne technique parce que
là vous pouvez pas vous tromper ben non
parce qu'on est tous coupables dans
cette affaire
et pourquoi voulez-vous peu moins
j'agisse
quand il y en a qui est plus coupables
que moi
ou plus légitime comment agir
je m'appelle frédéric joly
j'ai passé près de vingt ans dans une
industrie de passion et l aéronautique
pendant des années j'ai lutté
j'ai lutté parce que ce que je voulais
pas regarder
je veux pas regarder cette réalité
une réalité qui pourrait me demander de
renoncer à mes aspirations à ce que
j'avais construit
puis un jour un peu un peu par curiosité
un peu par hasard
j'ai voulu quand même en savoir plus
alors j'ai tiré la pelote comme ça
j'ai lu des livres j'ai lu des rapports
j'écoutais des conférences
et ça m'est tombé dessus un jour
une sensation que je suis sûr que
certains ici connaissent
la sensation de merger
sensations vous sentez les fondations
qui va si vous perdez vos repères
une sensation où chaque geste
vous demande un effort démesuré
parce que vous savez plus pourquoi vous
le faites
alors j'ai décidé d'agir mais je savais
pas trop par où commencer
alors j'ai écouté j'ai beaucoup écouté
j'ai parlé tous les jours
pas laisser passer une journée sans
parler du changement climatique et de
l'effondrement du vivant
et j'ai tellement parlé qu'aujourd'hui
j'en ai fait mon métier
aujourd'hui c'est des milliers de
personnes que j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
devant moi pendant une heure une journée
parfois plus
et à chaque fois
on sait poser pour réfléchir à ce que
j'ai appelé le pouvoir du jeu
le pouvoir du jeu c'est se poser la
question qu'est ce que je peux faire
qu'est ce que je vais vers
le pouvoir du jeu
c'est le meilleur moyen de se forcer à
regarder la réalité en face
et ça ça m'a donné une nouvelle énergie
l'énergie qui s'est nourri de tous ces
petits moments où j'ai pu avoir en face
de moi des déclics
quelqu'un qui va comprendre ce qui se
passe ou quelqu'un qui va s'engager
s'engager à plus prendre l'avion à moins
utiliser sa voiture à réduire sa
consommation nation de viande à moins
consommer peut-être
la semaine dernière la ville de
strasbourg a inauguré lé autoroute a355
c'est plus de 32000 véhicules qui sont
attendus tous les jours sur ce tronçon
le 10 novembre dernier donc en plein
pendant la coop à glasgow
la chine a extrait en une seule journée
plus de 12 millions de tonnes de charbon
ca record
ça sert à quoi tout ça
ça sert à quoi tout ce qu'on fait les
petits pas
encore une sensation
une autre sensation que certains ici
connaissent
la sensation de se sentir tout petit
tout petit face un système qui s'emballe
une machine qui va trop vite de plus en
plus vite
une sensation qui inhibe
encore une sensation qui donne envie de
baisser les bras d'arrêter d'agir
pourtant j'étais pas loin du but
c'est juste que je pas la bonne question
il ya une limite au pouvoir du jeu
jeu
commencé cette activité je me suis
retrouvé face au directeur financier
d'un grand groupe et toute son équipe
va l'appeler jean-pierre
voyez avec jean pierre et son équipe ont
mené un exercice de projection se dire
qu'on se place dans un monde en 2030 qui
a réussi la transition qui a diminué de
moitié les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre on s'interroge c'est quoi une
entreprise dans ce monde là c'est quoi
des clients des consommateurs des
investisseurs c'est quoi le rôle des
territoires de l'état
et puis après on se ramène à aujourd'hui
on se pose la question c'est quoi les
actions qu'on doit prendre aujourd'hui
pour exister dans ce futur souhaitable
quand il fait le tour de jean pierre
donc imaginez vous la jean pierre sellal
femme à la dominant la pièce tout son
charisme jean-pierre il se lève comme çà
il prend sa petite note ils valent
apposée sur le mur et avec toute son
autorité
il décrète
la fin des gobelets en plastique à tous
les étages de la direction générale
on avait passé toute la matinée à aller
dans le détail des mécanismes du
changement climatique
a regardé les enjeux les phénomènes
l'urgence et à ce moment là tout ce que
peux me trouvais jean-pierre c'est les
gobelets en plastique
champions 1 évidemment il sépare que si
j'avais posé les mêmes questions aux
dizaines de milliers de ses
collaborateurs
j'aurai des gens qu'il m'aurait dit je
sais pas peut-être qu'il faut isoler nos
usines
changer notre système de production
changer notre modèle d'affaires
mais on peut pas parce qu'on n'aura
jamais le budget parce que la direction
générale ne voudra jamais le risque est
trop important
jean-pierre c'est un point de blocage
sans le savoir
et vous savez quoi
nous sommes tous des points de blocage
sans le savoir
alors depuis j'ai changé ma question
dans les ateliers
je ne m'arrête plus ah qu'est-ce que je
peux faire qu'est ce que je vais faire
parce que beaucoup plus intéressant
c'est la question qu'est-ce que je ne
peux pas faire
qui me bloque team inhibe qui m'empêche
de voir grand
et la mission que je veux vous proposer
ce soir c'est d'oser
osé identifier votre jean pierre avoue
et après osé lui parler
vous et lui écrire rassemblez vous à
plusieurs si c'est plus facile mais
allez-y écrivez à votre mère écrivez à
votre député écrivait à tout les
candidats tous les candidats de
l'élection à venir écrivez à votre chef
à votre directeur à votre direction
générale
parler
et vous savez ce qui va se passer
rien
bah non puisque jean-pierre est point de
blocage
mais l'enjeu c'est pas d'obtenir un oui
l'enjeu cdd jean-pierre a progressé
et peut-être qu'il en faudra de dix ou
cent des comme vous pour qu'un jour
jean-pierre à son tour
accepte de regarder en face la réalité
et intègre à son tour le pouvoir du jeu
ce soir
mon jean pierre à moi c'était vous
alors je vous retourne la question
c'est qui votre jean pierre quand est ce
que vous allez lui parler merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]